if English is your second language just
getting through that paragraph I mean
that is a dense stupid pair crap in 2014
South Korea was ranked number one in the
world for overall cognitive skills and
educational attainment by Pearson
Education though exemplary in its
success the Korean education system
places pressure on students that can
compromise their happiness and health
the average South Korean high school
student only receives five-and-a-half
hours of sleep each night in order to
accommodate up to 13 hours spent
studying in a day a 2010 survey found
that of suicidal South Korean youth 53%
felt the cause was their inadequate
performance in school this suggests a
link between self-worth and academic
performance we invited some of our
BuzzFeed co-workers to solve a couple
questions from the foreign language
section of the South Korean SAT from
2011 these questions had some of the
highest incorrect answer rate in the
history of the test I went to an Ivy
League school I did great on my SATs I
have two degrees from Stanford
University I did very well on my
Senators tests I graduated from UC
Berkeley in 2015 I'm interested to see
how much harder it is I don't have
confidence if so many people screwed up
certainly know better at language than
most the world
number 28 journeys are the midwives of
thought so already you've got these
abstract concepts which is already a
tough idea to wrap your head around few
places are more conducive to internal
conversations than a moving plane ship
or train there is an almost peculiar
correlation between what is in front of
our eyes and the thoughts we are able to
have in our heads large thoughts at
times requiring large views new thoughts
new places introspective reflections
which are liable to stall are helped
along by the float landscape the mind
blank when thinking is all it is
supposed to do the tasks can be as
paralyzing as having to tell a joke or
mimic an absent on-demand thinking
improves when parts of mine are given
other tasks as charged with listening to
music or following line trees these
questions are already three times the
length of questions on the American SAT
they are saying as
contrast it to a journey when thinking
is all the mind is supposed to do that's
like going to be something negatives I'm
looking for something negative here this
is very confusing that sentence the
tasks can be is paralyzing is heavy to
tell a joke or maybe good acts and
demand feels like it's from a totally
different passage though trough so many
people I'm going to say it's one I'm
going with one I think it should be
maybe reluctant to think properly what I
mean yeah I'm making my mom proud I'm a
texter 82% that's worse than random
guessing means this is a particularly
bad question it's a [ __ ] up question
number 26 here we go the big question
that everyone got wrong so far as you
are wholly concentrated on bringing
about certain result clearly the quicker
and easier it is brought about the
better
oh what a difficult thing to have two
parts together okay
you're resolved to secure a sufficiency
of food for yourself your family will
induce you to spend weary days in
tilling the ground and tending livestock
but if nature provided food and meat in
abundance ready for the table you would
thank nature for sparing you much labor
and consider yourself something an
executed purpose in short is a
transaction in which the time and energy
spent on the execution are balanced
against the resulting assets and the
ideal case is one in which oh the ideal
case is one which you get a lot of
assets and you don't spend any time on
purpose then justifies the efforts it
exacts only conditionally by their
fruits oh my god this last sentence oh
boy this is hard the ideal case is one
is which it doesn't take a lot of time
that's what I got out of it okay I feel
like it's number three I'm going number
five but my final answer
[Music]
thank you 90% that's the first thing
that I ain't checked off because I was
like it has numbers in it I would have
never gotten that when I learned Spanish
is much easier being like the dog ran to
the library instead of like the thing
about language theory is I would never
be able to understand that no foreign
language if you're talking about like
suicidal thoughts that takes like school
pressure to a whole new degree in Korea
like where you go to college that's your
whole life goal they're set up to fail
like look at these questions these
aren't like you're never gonna have to
talk like this it's so highly
specialized it doesn't need to be a
general standardized test I hope that
students can start to see academic
success success isn't the only validator
of who you are I have so much respect my
heart really goes out to you
[Music]